do you want to know how I celebrated my
book launch so my book has come out it's
super exciting it's been an amazing week
overwhelming chaotic working extremely
hard and I'm loving every minute of it
and one of the things that struck me on
on day one of when the book came out was
how much people wanted to celebrate and
I got a ton of emails from people
congratulating me and I had a bunch of
facebook messages and people were
tweeting me and saying congratulations
and taking pictures of themselves buying
the book and i love it i love all of it
and then i started doing a bunch of
media and I was doing radio shows and
podcasts in interviews and just constant
cons the whole day launch day was
basically just all day doing interviews
and one of the most common questions
that I got asked was how are you
celebrating first couple times it's a
guy you know whatever I didn't mean what
I said but I kept coming out by now you
know i'm not i'm not big on celebrating
just in general i think it's a weakness
and a strength I'm much more focused on
the marriage then the wedding day I
think too many people focus on the
wedding day and make it this huge thing
and just in general in life we focus on
on celebrating one thing where for me
the real celebration is in everything
afterwards like who cares about one day
and you care too much about the wedding
and not about actually having a happy
marriage right I know I apply that to
everything I don't I honestly don't care
much about book launch day I want the
book to be successful everything that
I'm doing and thinking is about the
longer term the bigger game because so
many books come out and push to hit a
New York Times bestseller list or
whatever it is and it was never really a
top priority for me it's much more about
I want people to read this because a lot
of those new york times bestsellers
where Amazon bestseller is all geared
around the one day and then it falls off
and the author can put bestseller on
their bio and I'm sure that's great but
again for me I want people to read it
like much more important than just
having a book to my name I want people
to read it I want you to
I want you to read the book apply it it
said it's a good book I'm proud of it
it's not just a sales and marketing tool
there's quality in there that will
change your life that's why I wanted to
reach people you know I don't really
care about the celebration too much so I
think that's the strength of that I care
so much about the mission I think the
weakness though is that other people
like to celebrate and there's a lot of
people on my team who've done a lot of
great work on this and my wife who
supported me through all of this and and
is good to show some recognition I so
that's probably a weak point for me as a
as an entrepreneur as a human being so
the thing that got me shifted on this
was you know people are asking me these
questions how you guys help me I'm I'm
working like I i I'm this is my this is
my celebration you're like I'm talking
to you you know I'm making videos I made
I made video after video after video of
just thanking people who read my book
who bought the block right making
customized videos for everybody who
bought the book and taking 30 seconds a
minute 90 seconds out of out of that day
to make a custom midi for somebody
what's up Jonathan Alexandra happy
Tuesday what's up man greetings from
toronto all the way out to jamaica
what's up aletta what's up goong you
happy tuesday so then i saw this post on
facebook from jay your eyes who had an
instrumental role in the book and it was
him at one of the biggest book stores
here in Toronto when he took a picture
of the book and he was there with a
friend and they both took a picture and
they posted the facebook and I started
getting some likes and that maybe you
know maybe I should maybe I should go to
a bookstore we should get out of just
work mode on the book answering emails
and go to a bookstore and and so we did
so Nina and I went out to a local
bookstore and found the books and and it
was great that they had some copies took
some pictures with them and and uh that
was a fun little moment and then she's
like what else do you want to do to
celebrate and like I don't know I'm
thinking again like I'm gonna go back I
gotta go bye i have more videos and i'm
gonna be up all night making videos for
people who bought the book
and then on the way home I thought you
know what let's go to McDonald's and i'm
not a big McDonald's fan I eat at
McDonald's maybe a couple times a year
uh you know the food just kind of makes
me feel a little gross after I eat too
much of it but the reason why i chose
McDonald's was I think I tell this
during the book when I was getting
started my first company I was not
making a lot of money right omega three
hundred dollars a month I couldn't
afford anything and anytime we had a
major win we would go to a local
McDonald's and share this three of us
would share a large fries and that that
was our celebration because I couldn't
afford more than that right and you know
watching every forget dollar every day
every penny you're watching every penny
and so that was the celebration like
let's go out and have some McDonald's
french fries and so for me McDonald's
french fries kind of represented a win
victory right the process and even when
i think about fri mcdonald's fries now
kind of smile and just it's good vibes
and good memories even though i know
they're terrible for you and I don't
need them much so I thought let's go to
McDonald's and get not just the fries
let's nina and i will share large files
but then i'm gonna get a big mac and I'm
gonna get a mcflurry oreo mcflurry with
caramel sauce because we're gonna
celebrate and this time i guess i can
afford a meal so we did that we did that
and and i was a nice little break fun
little celebration and then i went back
and started working again and making
more videos for people so that's how I
celebrate and I'm curious what you guys
do to celebrate I don't want to take my
eye off the ball I want to keep on you
know I want to support you guys I want
this to take off I want you to want you
to find your one word and apply it in
your life in business and I don't want
to let off the gas you know so what I
can see that sometimes you maybe need to
to support the people around you I don't
know that I'm that I miss it that much i
forget what the example was before um we
hit some milestone and Nina said you
should go out and celebrate and I went
out and bought myself a donut or
something and all I'm all I'm thinking
the whole time like I eat the donut
great and I'm
so yeah man I wasted half an hour there
I could have used that time to do
something else but I think I think
that's just awareness for me to know
that I don't really need the celebration
much but for the people around me in for
the team and you guys celebration is
important so I need to maybe and invited
a little bit more wait what should we do
something I know we're past book launch
day now but should we do something to
celebrate together the launch the book
we are going to be doing book review
club so we're going to every week I'm
going to be doing a call to go through
chapter 1 chapter 2 chapter 3 all the
way up to 7 and there's a link that we
can put in the description so that'll be
a form of celebration to kind of answer
questions but there's something else I
don't know give me thoughts let me know
you think I'm curious how do you
celebrate should we celebrate more
around the one word book let me know
leaving the comments below will answer
next week alright so let's get to some
of your comments from last week last
week I was talking about giving these
books away so we've got like 200 books
that I gotta give away I don't know how
to do it don't know what I should do
with them I want to make sure that
people get them are going to read them
and take action and not just have them
sit on a shelf and me some prize that
they won it support to me that you
actually do the work so let's go through
some of the comments and see what you
guys have in mind some ideas movable I
think that this book should go to
libraries and business schools the one
which will really appreciate it and use
it not any library business school like
this one librarian USA you mentioned the
livestream you will go there and sign
their book why not give them another X
number of copies I given this book the
libraries and business schools each copy
will surely be read multiple times over
for the years I think that it is really
is the way to make an initial impact
that's an interesting idea I don't know
how the library buying system works like
your people are asking for a book and
it's not there the people then do the
librarians then go and buy more copies
of it you know if if there's a lot of
demand dude libraries and go do it was
the book just sit look I'm sure for some
if you get Harry Potter the libraries
you have more than one copy of it and if
people keep asking for it to they order
more this is a pretty cool idea if the
line there's already that funnel where
that the library's already will order
more because it's adam and i like that
idea
I think actually then they'll take care
of it themselves but if people there's a
domain in the librarians aren't ordering
maybe there's because a budget or
whatever maybe there's a fit there I
don't want the book justice in a library
shelf probably better to send a library
Sheldon to sit on somebody shelf at home
buried in a box because at least the
library will somebody will see it
hopefully walking by greater chance of
it being used so I like that I like that
I let's give some additional thought
there i'd love to dive a little deeper
on that i like that next Tommy here's an
idea how have anyone who is interesting
receiving a copy of the book post post a
short youtube video stating why they
want to read the book this requires a
little effort so would help weed out
those people are not serious about it at
the same time some overwhelming task
people could shoot the videos on their
phones and upload that's an interesting
idea yeah I think people need to do
something I don't want it to be an
automatic window it's got it you gotta
put some effort into it thinking I don't
know there's something else what else
people have but by anybody who says just
can I have one that's not how this works
I need some ideas guys the whole point
is you got to put some effort into this
who can figure out a way to make it work
Diana every student in high school and
college should be mandatory weed I love
that Diana if you guys have connections
in the school board's I man if
self-awareness and entrepreneurship was
taught more in schools can you imagine
can you imagine man I'm digging that I
would love that yeah maybe there is a
way to connect with with high schools
too I don't know put it on the
curriculum if there's something involved
with that I'm a hundred percent on board
next up hombre this I bet hmm if you
give them away make it a non ask gift
when people get unexpected gifts they do
appreciate them but if they asked for
the thing to be given than they don't I
could I could look at the most loyal
members of believe nation and give out
books but you know what like a lot you
guys already have them there Eddie in
your house you're already breeding
through them I think the people who love
this channel most have already III know
you guys I know your names and I
recognize the names on the list they've
already bought it I do I like the idea
of having a surprise but again I don't
know that you're going to read it I
think you don't
appreciate things that uh that are that
you don't you don't pay for in some way
whether those monetary or some other
ways so this is the challenge I'm
feeling Brittany I think a launch party
for your book my help you can let people
know about the debut book and they will
get a free book of the attend maybe you
can charge five dollars to get into the
door just some thoughts that's cool
Brittany and I recognize your name I
know you but you bought a book I
appreciate that yeah maybe back to the
idea of celebrating I don't do enough
celebrating I don't know how many people
are here in Toronto whoo-hoo we could
have a fun launch party around or maybe
I mean I have a space right after on a
guy's house I could easily do something
there book signing event or something
maybe we give the profits to charity or
something I don't know maybe there's
something there hmm hmm maybe there's
something there maybe we do a charity
event at tds for anybody who wants to
come to Toronto and I signed the book
and we give the money to charity and
write it down something there or could
be a different city to just it's easy
for me in Toronto next up the Kiro great
muscles Nina go got to get back to the
gym yeah Nina Nina the Nina was flexing
in last week's video so yeah that she's
she's just working and she's crushing it
you can have people say the reasons they
want the books the reasons that they
want to win the book could be good i
want to feel some passion I like that
it's not an automatic win you got to
show something in there Sean I dance
salsa Miami you have to come to Miami
salsa congress brother I've never been
to the Miami salsa congress it might man
we might or maybe we bring miami heat to
toronto come on up come on up to the
Toronto come up to Toronto dance salsa
Shawn let's see your moves we'll do a
video together let me know man next up
maverick ever do you have a video
talking about what your book is about
why you wrote it if not please do one
I've done a few bucks done a few book
videos I mean there's been this whole
series that were an episode whatever now
it's crazy what episode is this let me
see again episode hold on 78 episode 78
we've done 78 videos talking about the
book in the process
also done some standalone videos on the
channel but listen bro I respect the
opinion if there's something that you
feel is missing if there's a video tell
me what you want to see in the video and
I'm gonna make that video for you man if
I've been unclear and something or
something you still want to learn then
let me know and I'm open to that from
everybody you want to see a certain kind
of video I'll do it I'm up for Tamra fun
video and love your muscles need a
hashtag Nina has muscles it's true Nina
is strong she's strong physically strong
emotionally I'm a big fan haven't I feel
the same way but you didn't give away
your books or someone who may not even
read it I don't have an answer for you
I'm waiting on me off my 10 books to
arrive I don't have anyone picked out
yet to give it to because I really
really really want them to read the book
right under percent like if you for
those of you who are buying it as gifts
because it's Christmas time or you want
to support you want you want to see them
have progress in their lives you don't
want to give somebody a gift or not
going to use right if I bought 10 books
I want to make sure that the book i'm
giving that person to like that they're
gonna read it you're gonna read it Jer
eyes hashtag ec viewing party might be
something there might be something there
next up Amy make a contest they have to
win it we could do that we could combine
some of those things ideas we forgot
making a video and why you want or why
you want it maybe I would auction off a
box maybe I take one of the box doesn't
say listen there's how many books in
this box and make a video and the best
whatever however many are in a box
videos win it could be some kind of like
I don't want to live with the only
people who have a youtube channel like
if your if your skill is art maybe you
make art or you take a picture I don't
know there's something we're gonna come
up with something Kathleen hi I've never
seen my book today sweet I can't wait to
begin reading it good luck kathleen i'm
so excited for you let me know how it
goes if you have questions dr. queen bee
i haven't finished watching this video
yet but may say something you two are so
cute it's all Nina Nina brings the
cuteness to the channel we're not going
to get cute comments on this video
although Nina is right there so yeah I
like Aventine on the channel it's always
Mark J ger given to me I'll read them
mark you are massively successful
entrepreneur has been featured in some
amazing books at least one that I know
of amazing it's like one of the best
books of all time mark you should be
buying at least 100 copies give them
away come on mark I'd be an
extraordinary thing to do I'm just
saying Regina hey there when I just
bought your book on Amazon this morning
can't wait to read it love it Regina let
me know how it goes you guys have
questions let me know I want to answer
them for you Lynn 90210 give them the
struggling teenagers who need a bit of a
boost empower them for the rest of adult
life yeah again I would love to I would
love to it's how to identify those
teenagers right who are ready to receive
the message that's the big challenge
whether it's teenagers or entrepreneurs
you know that's the big challenge
finding those people who are ready
Xavier just be patient and worry about
selling a box at a time by the time you
know it they'll be gone take small steps
I don't really care about selling the
books it's not like I don't know how
much money that is it's it's whatever
200 books x x 20 bucks you know it's
like it's not it's not about selling the
books man it's about making sure that
the people who get it are going to do
something with it reem let people buy it
if someone really wants it and is
interested in your message they will do
anything to have it you want the
hustlers will do anything to make their
life better read every book apply every
piece of advice I'm with your room I'm
with your room I mean maybe we make it
as a as a bonus you know personalized
autograph version with a message or
something in there for the extra
hustlers who want to come out to an
event I'm loving all the feedback guys
this is this is good food for thought
melissa is writing in to suggest that we
give it two groups who have book clubs
or churches or high school students and
leave posts on discussion boards or
skyping the session that's interesting
there's a book club that might want to
read it I think if you're a part of a
book club is why I wanted to do my
online book club if you're part of a
book club you're much more likely to
read it because you're accountable to
somebody else so that's interesting
that's interesting thank you for that
next up tmrw tmrw bought 10 copies of
the book so thank you for that tomorrow
I hope you're enjoying them and they're
in your Haynes suggestion haibin you
should one give the books away too loyal
fans but have them pay for shipping yeah
I get like it's not the
odd maybe me I maybe I didn't explain
that like the cost of sending it is not
I'm not worried about that the revenue
from selling the books I'm not worried
about that if we give the kiva or
something else that's not it's not what
I'm really concerned about I guess the
pain for shipping is that enough to get
somebody to then read the book that hey
I paid four bucks for shipping or
whatever it is that now I'm going to
that's enough as an investment to to get
the book maybe Crete 20 book clubs
around the country and after one week to
a live chat via Skype or Google hangout
ooh that's interesting instead of mine
or I guess in addition to mine doing 20
having people who want to launch their
own book club locally and then being
willing to do a hangout with them I like
that well let me know guys do whatever
you want to do a local book club and
then at the end of it chat with me to
talk about the book I'm up for that man
I'm down you put that on the list I
think that could even be an interesting
marketing strategies to go to all the
book clubs and say here's what we're
doing Evan would be happy to have a
session with you guys at the end of the
book club too I like that tamyra man Oh
is showing some love I love this 3
letting a staffing the / marketing
company like mine shout at the high top
talent com or loyal fan of your
challenge represent you and create a
marketing video asking people around
town what is there one word or even a
for suggestion going to book two or ten
cities and market your book meet your
fans and push your sales you can do
whatever and i believe the hashtag Tim
came it's something I'm thinking about
doing a book tour my publisher doesn't
want me to do it because it never
returns you don't make basically make
enough sales for a book tour to cover
the cost of travel and all that stuff
but meeting fans I don't know I loved it
I loved meeting you guys it's that's
that's joy for me man maybe we do I you
know when I'm writing it down I'm
writing it down I'm writing it down
ten-city book door meet fans sign copies
I think I think that could be something
fun to do next up juni students will
read anything that teachers a sign for a
course so ask a few teachers
entrepreneurship from different
universities if they're interested to
teach it in their core
I like that that could work I don't have
the connections in two teachers but if
any of you guys are teachers I want to
have it as recommended reading for your
students or you know a teacher who would
potentially do that let me know I'm very
curious to have a conversation see if
that's a potential path the be thong
since i pre-ordered the book i would
take an extra book from your hundred
ninety-five announce my way to convince
me why i should give it to them this way
your book gets more attention if other
youtubers like me would do it so it's
interesting give it to you tubers and
then have them say to their audience why
should you get the one word book I think
you'll work i think i got to get on the
radar of that youtuber first to have
them be passionate about it interesting
guys there's some good food for thought
i love it you can always count on the
leaf nation to come through with some
ideas i'm gonna i'm going to give it
some more thought whether we give it to
libraries do some kind of i like idea of
doing like a one box giveaway to you
guys believe nation if you do something
some kind of charity event at tds local
launch party something around the local
book clubs or like that working with
youtubers and then the some kind of tour
good food for thought guys i love it if
there's anything else let me know leave
it down the comments below and back to
the initial topic about celebration if
we should do something as believe nation
to celebrate what ideas you might have
let me know in the comments below and
then if you have any questions about the
book going through the book for those
you who've bought it you need help with
it leaving the questions in the comments
below and if you just have questions
about the book writing process you're
trying to write your own book you're
trying to get a publisher any of that
stuff it's been a long journey and if i
can help then i'm happy to leave it down
below thank you guys so much for
watching are you know I can't express
enough how much I value you guys your
input your feedback your loyalty your
love your encouragement your motivation
you know I motivate you guys but it
definitely comes back you guys motivate
me to keep doing this stuff so I really
really appreciate that
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love guys I'll see you
soon